what's up ladies and gentlemen today we
have a very special video for you I am
joined by my friends who all have their
own amazing channels but when we come
together like this to collab we are the
golden company in this video is our
first official collaboration together I
am joined by grey area
secrets of the Citadel in Cowes [ __ ]
chickens since this is our first video
together we decided to bring you
something epic and who better to discuss
than Jon Snow in this video we will list
all of our predictions for this
character starting at season 7 episode 1
until the season 7 finale but before we
get started does everyone want to say
what's up to the listeners that sounds
good dude this is Kyle's [ __ ]
chickens and I'm happy to be a part of
the golden company really excited our
word is as good as gold
beneath the gold the bittersteel get
hype everyone hi this is Gemma from
secrets of the Citadel I'd love to be
joining you all today over to you gray
hey guys it's gray area and I'm here to
talk from Jon Snow with the fellow
golden company members and you guys we
had to give you all this Kyle would you
like to start us off and let everyone
know where Jon Snow's story left off at
the end of season six so we know that
jon is in a unique position now we saw
the vision from bran stark last season
obviously with some huge implications we
know that Leanna is part of the equation
that is his mother that is something
that we've been looking forward to for
quite some time in the game of Thrones
in the Song of Ice and Fire series and
he's the king in the north now we saw
pianist Lyanna Mormont speak up for him
and and everybody all the bannermen are
basically behind Jon which is crazy so
got a lot of different alliances going
on and we have Littlefinger in the
background so there's going to be some
stuff that we're going to have to sort
out obviously chance of being there it's
very important and obviously you have
support through Davos who I think will
be his hand of the king and in
Littlefinger's in the background going
to be trying to be meddling with what's
actually going down with all the
synchronization in the north now that
it's stabilized with the Bolton's gone
so I think there's going to be some
really interesting stuff going down
which on obviously in episode one we're
going to have to tie up all the loose
ends and the rulings in North because I
think that little finger is going to be
a problem
I completely agree that look little
finger on songs a shared definitely has
me curious as to what's going to be the
result of that when we start back up in
season seven because you know the little
finger is definitely up to something and
as soon as Jon Snow turns his back or
leaves Winterfell little finger will get
back to work trying to continue to
manipulate Songza even more he will
probably continue to tell her that Jon
Snow is a bastard as if she doesn't know
that and that he doesn't deserve to be
king nor does he deserve any lands
especially Winterfell and that
everything should be hers I'm really
looking forward to seeing this plot
thread play out but gray area when
season seven begins what do you think we
will see Jon do first what will be his
first order of business I think his
first order of business is probably
making appointments he has a lot of
appointments to make like when Ned left
and took everyone with him
Catelyn had a lot of appointments to
make but Rob actually winded up making
them so I think the same is for Jon like
he's going to have to have a hand he
could have to have a mace master horse
and all of that stuff and I also think
he's going to get some Ravens one from
King's Landing and one from dragons own
and he's going to have to make a choice
what are you thinking secrets he's got
one focus and he's the only one that
knows about the White Walkers is the
only one that really understands that
the rest and I think he's going to be
laser beam focused on that I mean he's
got to get his house into order and
he'll have to put people in the right
places he needs to get the north in
order and the knobs been decimated this
that there's a lot of problems going on
in the North remembers but there's
problems and now he's king of the north
so it's his job to sort that out without
the north
he can't go and fight the White Walkers
so yes he's going to be focused on the
White Walkers and beyond the wall but
he's got so much
to get organized first unfortunately I
think he's going to find it frustrating
and but we shall see I think he will
embrace his role as king of the north in
a way that you might not have done prior
to him being killed and I think that's
one of the subtleties we are seeing in
him being resurrected I was hoping for a
bigger chair Ange how about you did you
think that he changed enough I'm
actually not sure how much he has
changed as of right now he definitely
appears to be more fearless like we saw
during the Battle of the bastards when
he was trying to save Rick on when his
horse was shot with arrows and stumbled
and John fell off the horse he just kind
of stood there and stood his ground and
appeared to accept his fate at that
moment he didn't even flinch when those
horses were charging at him that was
kind of surprising and I don't think I
could have just stood there like that
but I think John definitely understands
death a little better at this point and
he even told Melisandre if I die do not
bring me back that is a fearless thing
to say so he definitely isn't afraid to
die now but we know that the Lord of
Light at least in Melisandre's eyes has
different plans for Jon Snow
but what I'm also wondering is how many
men does Jon actually have at this point
during the Battle of the bastards his
army was completely decimated we know he
has some of the northern houses back now
and he has the Vale kinda assuming
Littlefinger will continue to play ball
which I doubt he will gray area I know
you just made a video about the size of
the northern army at this point how many
fighting men does John have mm well I
think he has about ninety four thousand
ninety four thousand men and that's with
all the northern houses the wild lanes
the men of the Vale that was even
including some men from the river lands
and stuff so yeah ninety four thousand
that's actually not too bad then so Kyle
when John does eventually leave
Winterfell to make more alliances to get
his army even bigger and stronger
because the knight king in his army are
inevitable
coming I think we all can agree that the
wall will come down or they will come
through the wall or around the wall over
the wall whichever the case may be
but I think we all believe they're going
to make itself and John is not fully
equipped to fight them right now he
still needs more men into proper weapons
to supply all those men
so when Johnson Oh does lead to take
care of these issues who will he leave
at Winterfell to stay in charge and hold
down the fort well I mean sense is going
to be left behind I think that you know
a lot of people are making the dissents
a little finger connection and people
are saying that she's going to betray
John I don't think that's going to
happen as we saw as we just spoke about
John's fireside the natural evolution of
John killing the boy becoming the man
he's becoming more of a firing leader
and I think people really rally behind
that so I think that he will leave Sansa
behind but he will also leave someone
like torment and and probably ghost
who's not really a human but I mean we
we all know how amazing kosis and and
and how amazing he was at with
protecting John we saw all the stuff at
the we saw all the stuff with the Nights
Watch how closely he guarded John and I
think that ghost would do the same
sensing the star quad within sansa so I
think you make a great point in
obviously and that Jemma made some great
points about how how aware John is about
this scenario with the white Walker
she's the one who is only truly thinking
about the future the very big picture so
I think that he's going to leave Sansa
behind reluctantly but there's people
like Lyanna Mormont and and more blubber
who are going to stay behind when he
takes Davos and he goes to Dragonstone
with him so I'm not as fearful as some
other people but I think Santa will be
in good hands with a good support
reflector in a tarp and those kinds of
people I agree with you and I hope he
does leave tormund behind the stay with
Sansa and like you said bran should be
there for her too she may not even know
they have Winterfell at this point
because she left to try and get support
from the blackfish for the Battle of the
bastards
but that battle ended up happening
already before she could even make it
back but I think we're all confident
that she will make it back to Winterfell
in Brienne will be a good person to have
it songs aside while John is gone
because we know how loyal she can be and
what she is willing to do in order to
protect
shawne's Oh like we saw in moles town
when her and Sons I met with
Littlefinger she actually grabbed the
handle of her sword and was ready to
kill little finger right there on the
spot
so with tormund Brienne and possibly the
Hound could make it there Sansa could
end up with a pretty strong support
group there with her while John is gone
just in case Littlefinger will try and
stab John in the back and claim
Winterfell for himself while he is gone
if I can add one more point I saw
something funny the other day if we Ana
Mormont had three dragons the show would
be over in two seasons I think we got to
think about her so that's that's uh
she's of course to be reckoned with man
she she got the whole speech started so
I think my aunt Lyanna Mormont will have
a bigger impact than we think yeah
she'll definitely be up there too I
don't really know what she could do
physically but you're right she does
have a very large voice but what I
wanted to ask one of you was we did get
a official photo from HBO that appears
to be John standing in the crypts do you
think John's going to go down into the
crypts before he leaves wonderful to go
south oh absolutely yeah that photograph
he was definitely in the crypts there's
no doubt about that and I think he was
probably looking at that statue that all
hoping he was looking at but I think
it's going to be a massive troll a big
tease it's going to be he's going to go
down there either to pay his respects he
will have to bury Rickon and he said
that in the end of the last season that
he has to take his brother down to the
crypts so you will be going down there
and there's going to be a moment of
fleeting glimpse perhaps at the statue
of lianna and the audience are going to
hold their breath and then he'll walk on
and we'll all be screaming at the TV and
that'll be that so now so you do think
he's going to look at our lianas tomb
before he leaves I do yes I really do
and I think it would just be a big piece
do you think he's going to do that
because he's just paying respects to his
entire family or do you think something
somebody's drawing him down there
ya know I think it will be more I think
there'll be a big question mark over
that was you just paying his respects
was something calling to him I think
there will be a moment that will we'll
be talking about for a long time and
that can be interpreted in many ways but
I personally feel that there will be a
draw like a present something that
causes him pause you know makes him stop
and just glance where he didn't expect
he would glance and he doesn't really
know why and the audience are going to
go crazy there's going to be videos
about it all over YouTube speculation
the works and but yeah I think this is a
draw I mean throughout the text those
clips are positively screaming at Jon
Snow to go down there and I think the
show will nod to that yeah I agree with
you and I love the idea that I hope they
do give us to that gray area what do you
think do you see John going down into
the crypts before he leaves and do you
think he will stop at lianas tomb I
absolutely think he's going to go into
the crypts I don't know if he if he goes
in the crypts right before he leaves or
right at the end of season seven like
when he gets back to Winterfell it looks
kind of like when he's leaving he
stopped them by the crypts he might want
to say a prayer to Ned because according
to the show you know Ned is in the crypt
because he says very Rickon next to my
father so he might he might want to say
something to Ned and maybe he finds a
harp or a dragon egg maybe he finds who
his mother is I have no idea what he's
going to do down there and I think you
did a video that a crow would leave him
down there yeah I definitely think it's
a possibility I mean we saw the
three-eyed raven lead brand to the
crypts so now that bran is the
three-eyed Raven I think he could do the
same for John now that brand knows who
Jon's mother is and you're right that
actually could be a photo from the end
of season seven bran could actually be
in that scene and he's just out of frame
like that could be brand taking him down
there
we just don't know it because they're
only showing Johnson Oh like a close-up
of Jon Snow what do you think about that
I think that I think that's possible I
think bran could just be out of the clip
and it's brand down there with him or
some I think he's down there I think
that's going to be like a pivotal moment
in the show and that might be the
cliffhanger that they they make us wait
another year
to see how that plays out Kyle what do
you think about this I think you guys
pretty much nailed all the points here
there's a few interesting things that
that I've been reading up on the crypts
of Winterfell and Ned I believe all the
kings of winter they get their crypts
before they die right so I think that
it's possible that Ned hid John's crypt
knowing how important he would be to the
family eventually or maybe you know
maybe he just put the crypt down there
because uh you know you know how close
he was with Leanna we know how fond he
was of Leanna his sister but I think
that it's possible that his crypt is
this hidden at a lower level we know
that he was hiding a lot of information
from Robert that's why he brought John
back to Winterfell in the first place
I tend to think that maybe his real name
is actually within the crimp in Linnton
Winterfell and in the books and through
the show we don't really get the same
thing from the books but in that story
what I was trying to say was in the
books in the show things are a little
bit different but in the books John
wonders why he doesn't belong that he
feels like he doesn't belong down there
so it's really interesting it'll be
really interesting to see as GEMA sad
and you guys said it's going to be one
of the biggest moments in the series I
think and because we all know how
special John is so for him to find out
his parentage perhaps the brand or
perhaps for brand to be part of that
process is really huge yeah what does
everybody else think about that do you
think John has his own tomb down there
and could possibly reveal his true name
does anybody have anything to add to
that um I'm not sure about that for some
reason I'm eeen it's definitely a
possibility but where Ned was so
protective and trying to hide about who
John was I don't think he would leave
any clues anywhere best is my opinions
but I mean it's a good possibility I
think if he does come
toom it will be like Kyle said on the
lower levels there is an area that is
blocked off from rubble and past that
curve on purpose perhaps ned stark's
brought that rubble there to make it
look like an area being caved in so no
one will go into that area and perhaps
that's where it is and I don't think it
will be openly on display I think it
would be somewhere that would have to be
actively sought out yeah you took the
words right out of my mouth I was
actually going to say it would be risky
for Ned to do that like gray said but it
could be in those lowest levels where
the crypts are partially collapsed just
like you said so yeah if it is down
there like Kyle says then it would have
to be in those lowest levels to where
nobody ever goes Kyle what I want to ask
you is when John snow leaves Winterfell
to head south or wherever he's going to
go to make these alliances who do you
think he's going to take with him I
think it's going to be solely Davos and
there's good reason for that I think
John is still going to be skeptical on
all the things that are happening in the
north obviously the armors and the
Karstarks they've betrayed the stark
family after thousands of years of
Allegiance or hundreds of years of
alesia's story and I think that we saw a
Taoist is worth especially on Bear
Island dad was really proved himself not
that he had to I think that a lot was
known about Dallas or his inner workings
with Stannis Baratheon
but I think that Davos is the perfect
man for the job I'm a firm believer that
John's going to be kinging in the dab
which will actually be handed the King
someone from flea bottom and he has a
lot and he has a lot in common with John
he came from flea bottom John's a
bastard they were both probably treated
in similar ways so I think that Davos
and John are kind of the dream team as
far as being pragmatic and knowing
what's really good for the realm they
really really actually care about the
people so I think that it's just going
to be Davos and John it's going to be
more of a secretive mission I think that
they're going to be really low-key with
all with all the stuff going on in the
kingdom so I think that Davos and John
are going to be the only two that are
headed to drag himself
yeah I agree with you Davos is
definitely the man to take we know he's
probably the best negotiator in the show
and if you want to go anywhere to strike
any kind of deals or alliances then you
definitely need a smooth operator or
smooth talker like Davos because we've
seen John try to talk his way out of
things or negotiate terms and stuff like
that and it never worked out that well
for him but Davos usually strikes a deal
with pretty much anybody he's ever
spoken to kind of like we saw at the
iron bank than we saw with Lyanna
Mormont so you're you're right about
that
Davos would be the best man to take with
him does anybody else have anything to
add to that do you think John will take
anybody else besides Gestapo's
no I'm complete agreement and I feel
that Davos is an asset we know for the
reasons that you've just said and but I
also think he'll be really reluctant to
leave Winterfell unattended and
especially when you consider what
happens before when Catelyn and Rob and
everybody left brom and then obviously
Theon came in and did his thing
and so I don't think John will be
willing to leave Winterfell unattended
so he will essentially make that
sacrifice to go unarmed almost without
the backup because he'll feel prefer to
leave it at Winterfell I agree with you
guys I don't think he takes anyone with
him especially like when we see Catelyn
and Sir Roderick go down to King's
Landing they don't take a party with
them because they kind of don't want to
draw attention to themselves and that
kind of thing anyway and I don't think
he'll wants to leave when I think he
wants to leave as many men as at
Winterfell as he can
how do you think he's going to get down
there gray how I think and how I want
our two different two different things I
think he actually might take a ship from
white Harbor
so in none of the pictures that were
released we don't see any horses
anywhere I mean maybe we shouldn't see
horses on a beach or anything but we
don't see any horses visibly and we know
like the manderlys at white Harbor has
this
bleep I think that they might actually
ride up on this sea battle John and
Davos and they might be like picking up
some of the remnants the sea battle
could either be going on or over and
they might pick up some of the remnants
of the people in the water or something
and take them back to Dragonstone now
that would be very interesting I never
even considered that [ __ ] I like that
idea that straight fire like my mind
just exploded if I if I had the
soundboard ready right now I would press
a button ooh go choo-choo hype train all
aboard but I don't have to go I'll just
say it out loud yeah I did oh I never
thought of that possibility obviously
going to drag it so how long is it going
to take are they taking little figures
jet pack are they going there in one day
we know that we have a truncated period
of time in season 7 in season 8 we're
only getting 7 episodes in season 7 so
how fast do they get there how fast do
they negotiate with Daenerys and all of
them it's going to be really interesting
so is the battle go down episode 1 and
and then there they're like episode 2
may be but do they leave right away or
right at the end of the episode I got to
assume they got to be at Dragonstone by
episode 3 right yeah degree I think
episode 1 Jon's gonna have to set up
shop and get everything in place and 1
well before he takes off yeah definitely
an agreement there I think gray made
some great points I don't have much more
to add other than I think that Davos is
an amazing asset for John and they got
to make quick moves because the night's
king and his army are moving pretty fast
and pretty much everyone else is
oblivious so absolutely right singer to
the Citadel what do you think John goes
first to try to make these alliances
well I think he's going to be in the
process of getting his house into order
I think he's going to be focused on that
and then I think like gray said earlier
on and a couple of Ravens are going to
land and he'll be getting one from
Cersei from King's Landing you know come
over here and bend the knee and all of
that jazz and then he'll get one from
Daenerys say message and any
you'll have to make a choice and I think
you know dragons are have a little bit
more firepower than lions so I think
he's going to go to Daenerys but not to
bend the knee not to swear fealty to
basically tell her tell Daenerys that
look this is what's going on this is
what's important these Thrones and none
of this matters and we basically need to
get those dragons and bring them down to
the wall and sort this out because
otherwise we're all screwed basically do
you think when John receives the raven
from King's Landing from Cersei saying
she's the new queen Ben Danny do you
think he'll just send it back saying
return to sender go [ __ ] yourself
he had pretty much yeah he focused like
I said his focus is going to be night
King Knight range night King on the show
at White Walkers that's what he's
interested in he knows that what's
important and he may consider at a later
date to go to Cersei and say you know
you need to join all of us we all need
to join together
that's what Davos said wasn't it and
you're wonderful
yeah and but I think first and foremost
is going to go where the firepower is
and he's going to go to Daenerys so
thirsty' it's just an ass to wait I'm
afraid yeah I completely agree with that
does everybody think jon is heading to
Dragonstone solely or do you think he's
going to make any stops on his way there
first I think he is going to drag and
film I I don't even know if his original
destination will be dragons own like
maybe he says I'm going to go to King's
Landing or I'm going to go this Landis
land and he stumbles upon dragons flying
around and he's like oh I need to go to
Dragonstone or he just but I don't think
he's going to have time to do anything
like with seven episodes left by episode
three he has to be in Dragonstone so I
don't think he'll make any stop
he takes the water he's not going to
make any steps but if he takes the
kingsroad he's going to make probably a
lot of stuff yeah I agree with that when
he does make it to Dragonstone how do
you think they're actually going to
greet John because we know
Daenerys she wants the throne well she
might not technically want the Iron
Throne but she wants to remove Cersei
from power and she wants the Targaryen
specifically herself in power of
Westeros so when John shows up talking
about we need to go north there's a
great war that's north that's more
important than everything else you're
doing down here how do you think they're
going to receive John down on
Dragonstone um I think that they might
receive him well I don't she needs to
make alliances she has these big numbers
but I really think she is going to lose
a lot of people in this sea battle I
think she's going to lose at least half
of her army so she's going to be needing
alliances she's going to need these
houses and she's going to need John she
might not know it off the bat but she's
going to need him and I don't I've never
seen her be blatantly disrespectful to
anyone that didn't deserve it and I
don't have any reason to believe that
John is going to come at her like a
[ __ ] I need you to come do this I don't
think I think he's going to be
respectful so he'll be received
respectfully and then she's got Tyrion
there and Tyrion knows John so he can
kind of mediate for yeah I definitely
think Tyrion will be the one to kind of
bridge that gap Tyrion has relationships
with Jon and Daenerys he don't know John
as well as he knows Dany at this point
but we all saw their relationship at the
wall and they did become friendly before
they kind of went their separate ways
with John staying at the wall and
carrion going back down south in my eyes
it felt like they were fond of each
other at that point because Tyrion was
no longer
Ahlan John a bastard he did call him
Lord snow and then John was no longer
calling him the IMP he called him he
said you know I'm sorry to see you go my
lord so I think John and Tyrion will
kind of rekindle that relationship
Kyle how do you think this is going to
go over when John gets to Dragonstone
how do you think Tyrion and Daenerys is
going to receive John when he when he
gets there talking about a forget the
crown I need you up north well you guys
made you guys has made the connection
with Carrie and John and obviously
Tyrion imparted some knowledge onto John
very very early on in their workings
together so when they travel to the wall
we obviously saw that camaraderie and
that was very important we knew that at
some point they would get back together
and perhaps that Tyrion would be a
bridge between John and someone else so
that's really important they may
encounter some some trouble on the way
to Dragonstone we do know that
shipbreaker bay is right there so maybe
you're on is going to ambush someone
there and maybe that's what you know
maybe Grey's right on the right track
there so they know how important it is
to get to Tyrion and and really solve
all this stuff because not only the
White Walkers coming but there's all
this other stuff going on so I think
that the sides will be amicable for the
most part and Tyrion will be a big part
of that hearing a Davos together
obviously Davos has seen a lot in his
workings with Stannis Stannis was very
rigid he did waver a lot on the things
status didn't waver very much in what he
thought and he had Melisandre in his ear
and I think that John is a little bit
more open-minded Spanish so I think that
they'll be able to work together and I
think that Daenerys overall I think
she'll be really smitten by John because
he won't want to bend the knee right so
she likes these strong male type of
characters who are really confident in
themselves so I think that it won't go
over good at first but later on Tyrion
will really smooth things over and he'll
say hey listen like we really need you
you need to get rid of my crazy sister
she's the mad queen she blew up the Sept
of Baelor and then John will be like
listen we really need you so I think
they will come to some sort of
compromise in the end and it will be
pretty sweet Tyrion and John back
together that's going to be one of the
best moments of the season I think yeah
absolutely and we know
arian was starting to believe the threat
beyond the wall - like when him and John
were first travelling to the wall
we know Tyrion kind of said that that
line he's fed to him and said you don't
really believe in grumpkins and snarks
and stuff like that but we know Tyrion
started to become friends with maester
aemon and Lord Commander Mormont they
started to tell Tyrion about the threat
beyond the wall and how badly they
needed men and when Tyrion got back to
King's Landing
he told Cersei they need men and Cersei
basically gave Tyrion back his same line
saying you don't believe in grumpkins
and snarks and or Mormont would not lie
so at that point I think Karin was
starting to change a little bit he was
starting to believe that there was a
threat beyond the wall so I think that
will help Jon a little bit when Jon
comes down and starts preaching about
the night King and White Walkers Tyrion
could help Jon when it comes to
negotiating or trying to build this
alliance with Dany saying hey you know
Jon's not a liar he's been at the wall
he knows what's going on the Lord
Commander Mormont in there maester told
me these things so I would believe Jon
if he says there's a threat you know
there is a threat and as you know I'm
all about the books I mean I love the
show and I love the books both
separately and but in the books when
Alliser thorne comes to King's Landing
with the hand and that then rotted away
by this point and it's a Tyrion chaps
and so it's Tyrians point-of-view and
he's not buying it at all he does have a
momentary fleeting thought about when he
was stood on the wall and he was looking
out and and he had that foreboding
feeling but but then he does dismiss it
and I think he will trust Jon's word
though like you said Jon been there he's
been at the wall he knows what's out
there who who better to know what's out
there than Jon Snow and I and I think if
the world any doubts the Sirians
ultimately you will believe the word of
which friends that will
things they said to each other they
shook on it they said they were friends
and that's that's a big foreshadowing to
how that relationships going to come
back around in the future and that's
happening now so I think suburbs as well
will vouch for John I think Tyrion and
DevOps are going to see that the glue
for Daenerys and John and I think
Daenerys is going to go with the shock
and all Hey look I've got dragons and
she's going to expect a certain
reception that then she's not going to
get from Jon Snow like Kyle said she
might secretly quite like that but
ultimately I think they're going to be
at odds with each other but then they've
got Tyrion and Java that that will bring
them together I think without to in and
Davos Dany and John might be a different
story do you think Danny is going to ask
John to bend the knee yes I do I think
she's going to expect him to I think
that's why she will send a raven and
he's not going to because he's not
interested that's not what's important
and maybe he does um no no is that is
not it's not going to definitely not
what do you think about that great if
John shows up and Danny says Ben Danny
what do you think he's going to say to
her how do you think he's going to react
to that he's gonna give it to her like
Mance Rayder we do not know we do not
kneel I hope he does I hope he hits her
with that line yeah I don't think he's
going like like I agree with um what
secret said like he's a new person and
he has this like no I don't say isn't
like he doesn't care but he just has
this new attitude about him I don't I
don't even want to know know if it said
attitude but it's just like his presence
is demanding now like you said when he
got off the horse he was kind of
like like [ __ ] it basically like I'm
just going for whatever so I feel like
anything that has been on his mind where
that has bothered him for his whole life
whether it be him being a bastard which
I don't think affects him anymore but I
can't see him giving away his crown that
he just got for Daenerys not that it's
not that it's important and that it's
important for him but she was the only
way he's going to bend the knee is if
it's beneficial to the realm if he's
going to get her dragons in her army to
help fight the White Walkers then he'll
bend the knee but that's the only way
he's going to bend the knee yeah I kind
of like how you added in because we did
see Jon Snow say that demands you know
like just bend the knee like if it's
going to save your people just do it and
John could be put in that same position
to where Danny might refuse him and say
well the other way I am going to give
you some help is if you bend the knee we
could I mean I guess we could see John
in a similar position to where he's kind
of forced to bend the knee in order to
help or save his people and I think then
just like you said he would do it then
right because when John says I think he
was talking to something he says I've
killed men that I admire men that he was
talking about man so he did admire man
and though you know whatever they had
their beef or whatever but he admired
him so I think he's going to be like
like you say man he's not going to kneel
unless it's to benefit his people and
don't forget Toland stock the king that
melts I mean there was a lot of history
repeating itself so you know Turin did
that for the good of his people for the
northern man no northern men left his
bones on the field of fire that day and
so you know maybe he will I agree and no
northern men swords
were put on that Iron Throne yeah that's
a very good point if Danny is kind of
mirroring Aegon's conquest
then we could see something similar to
that I like that you added that in there
that's true Arica I want to ask you this
then what else could John be going down
the Dragonstone for we know he's out of
dragonglass
we know Stannis said Dragonstone is full
of it do you think John will make that a
priority of his while he is there do you
think he's going to attempt to get some
of this dragonglass we know he needs it
do you see him actually trying to mind
some of that while he's down there or
getting men to come down and mine it for
the north well I actually think that's
going to be in the initial reason they
go I don't think it's going to be just
because of the parley with Daenerys I
actually think that that John's going to
have the bigger picture in mind and we
doing know that he sent Samwell Tarly to
the Citadel so obviously that's going to
be a hugely important thing in season
seven we do know that that's going to be
a big storyline Sam is far away from
John know and we do know that while Sam
is going to be finding stuff for the
Citadel's say John and Dallas are going
to be at Dragonstone so why not kill two
birds with one stone maybe he can see if
Daenerys is going to help he's probably
not too optimistic about the matter
because he does know that she used the
Iron Throne as her right and you know
the things that have been going on he
saw so much of the fighting so far he
may not be optimistic about trying to
make that relationship work but I think
he for-sure seize that opportunity to go
to Dragonstone to get that dragon glass
because John like Gemma said it
singularly focused on the war for Don
that is 100% coming so John John and
Alice are going to go to and and Davos
has already been there right so maybe
Davos has some more information that we
know about maybe maybe he's been to
these caves or maybe he hasn't but
thought about going in them so that
that's that's another thing right Davos
is another connection to Dragonstone and
we know that tyrion will be meeting with
john tyrion needs to read books because
his mind is so amazing you know that he
spoke to john about how all of this
knowledge is is important to tyrion
because he's a dwarf so it's perhaps
perhaps tyrion read about this as well
so i think that all of these things
coming together maybe tyrion will point
something out john will mention it and
then sharon will be like oh i read about
this
a book or maybe gavel so say hey you
know I was here before so one of those
scenarios will probably play out and I
do 100% think that they will get
dragonglass on dragons through gathers
does have that connection with dragon
stone plus he was a smuggler to and it's
I'm not saying they're going to have to
smuggle dragon glass out of there but he
would know how much a boat could hold in
weight so if they were to try to get a
bunch out of there you know Davos would
know how to transport that stuff better
than anybody how much do you think
they're actually going to get out of
there
do you think they'll get enough to
supply the whole north with some type of
dragonglass weapon whether it's a spear
or arrow tips how much do you think
they're going to get just the tip story
I did cert a funny joke but I know I
think that they're going to get quite
about quite a bunch of it obviously if
they go there why just get a little bit
John saw how massive the army was of the
night King obviously fire kills the
whites but what if the White Walkers can
replenish themselves we still don't know
100% that Dragon Claw dragonglass kills
them forever we saw that that Sam killed
one but what if the night's king cannot
be killed by just dragonglass right so
they might need more than we think and I
think they're going to be beginning I
mean Theon hopefully we can get some of
his archery badassery back into the
story we can see some of that we we know
that obviously grace saying that the
north the northern army is pretty huge
and all that so I'm thinking that they
were going to need a large amount like
you said that's a real I never thought
of that like dog that was as a smuggler
actually knowing how much he has to
bring into his boat like I mean imagine
he was smuggling like treasure and [ __ ]
with solid or sand back in the day when
they were really doing the various
things so I think that it will have to
give a large amount because they know
that they are going to be overrun in the
North Sudan later
speaking of Theon since you just brought
him up Kyle in his archery we know the
Greyjoy's have aligned themselves with
Daenerys and there's a good chance that
when John gets the dragon stone he's
going to run into Theon and I think
we've even seen spoiler photos of them
on Dragonstone together how do you think
that interaction is going to go down
between John and si
on when they actually meet again um I'm
not too sure I know beyond is actually
pretty freakin scared to John like
that's his whole reason and like he's
not going to the wall because he doesn't
want to get killed by John but I think
John is going to forgive him basically
because he helps Santa and he didn't
kill bran and Rickon but I don't think
John will ever respect him or accept him
to be part of any army that he's a part
of uh job is going to be absolutely
fuming even I you know it's what we were
to get it was so long ago but what Theon
did was was unforgivable and he betrayed
robb he betrayed grin and luin
you know the whole burning winter felt
that ramsey it was all because of beyond
just trying to impress his dad and but I
think John will very quickly realize
that this is not the same thing this is
not the man you know that cocky always
smiling always making a joke and young
man from Winterfell as a ward at
Winterfell he's going to realize that
this is this is a broken shadow or shell
of a man someone who he doesn't
recognize any longer and I think John
will back off and just pity him to be
honest I think Theon has a bigger role
ultimately but I think John will be
fairly dismissive of him when he
realizes that that this is not there's
no point you know yeah I like that
actually just like you said John is
definitely going to be pissed off and
furious at feeling but just like you
said he's going to see that Theon as a
shell of him former self he's just like
a beaten and battered man so you know
what's it going to do for John to slap
this guy around a flat will will turns
beyond into a wreck a gibbering
apologetic
math which like I said is not that
beyond that John will remember yeah I
actually think that might be why John
doesn't beat him up just because of when
he sees what type of man he is at this
point like he's a big [ __ ] you know I
mean he has every right to be I mean he
was brutally tortured for years I think
John will see that and kind of think
what's the point of beating this man
down anymore he'll definitely give him a
lashing but I don't know if he's really
gonna beat him up maybe just just one
slap yeah he deserves it that's funny
yeah I've never I don't see John as like
the bullying type and I think kind of at
this point picking on Seon is bullying
because he's just like you said he's a
shell of what he used to be yeah he
can't defend himself so it'd be kind of
pointless
what about Danny's dragons is John going
to meet one of these dragons are all
three of these dragons when he's there
and how's this interaction going to go
down do you think they're going to be
drawn to John kind of like they were
with Tyrion in a way yeah I definitely
think so I mean we do know that John has
malaria and blood within him we I think
most of us think that R plus L equals J
is the correct equation so I think that
we might have a scenario where where we
talked here I know I'm speculative that
Tyrion may be a seka Targaryen so that's
why they were so warm to him we could
have the similar scenario news fake news
fake me oh you're fake you're fake news
ha ha ha
now you heard it our first argument here
on the globin company but I think that
honestly yes I think it's going to
happen and it's going to be regal mmm
that's a spicy one spicy nugget for
y'all
I think he just walks up to the Dragons
I mean he might be a little apprehensive
at first but I just think he has that
mentality where like he doesn't have
anything to lose he has to risk
everything and I feel like he's just
going to walk up to drogon so I think
I think it's going to be drogon I think
he's going to go up to drogue on because
drogue on it's vague news whatever drove
that he had to get me back
drogon is the biggest dragon so I feel
like he's going to go up to the biggest
strike like when you when you're in high
school or here anywhere and you're
getting bullied or something and you
know it's a group of people around you
and they say if you go up to the biggest
one and knock him out the rest will fall
into line so he has to go up to drogue
on like if Danny or anybody is out in
him he has to go up to the biggest
dragon and just pet him and give him a
big kiss on the mouth he has to do it I
think it's gonna be drilled on and I
definitely think he's going to do it and
I think R plus L does equal J and I
think dragons know who John is how do
you think Danny is going to react to
that if he just goes up the drug on like
that do you think she will get jealous
in some type of way or do you think
she's going to be kind of curious as to
why drogon is [ __ ] with John she's
gonna be so turned on by it she's gonna
take him right back into Kraken John and
Jen right of my mouth well actually I
was thinking of something of this victim
cruda what's her yeah she's gonna like
that gone damnit Ella
yeah she's gonna be all queenly and keep
a poker face on you know but she's going
to be really impressed and and I agree
great it will be drogon definitely and
he's just gonna bite the bullet he do it
she likes to use the dragons you
remember when she had all of the the
masses in the Dragons Den pit under
marine and she was you know basically
Fresa D to feed them all and I think
she'll use some kind of show of power
and John will surprise her I don't think
he's going to hop on one and go for a
little tour around Dragonstone
our thing I think it will be another
tease and I don't I do agree our plus L
definitely equals J no doubt absolutely
no doubt but that's not going to happen
in season seven when John's not going to
find that out in season seven yeah I
agree with you I don't think he's going
to ride on a dragon in season seven
either I agree with you guys all right
folks we will actually in part one of
this discussion right here I broke the
video down into two parts for editing
purposes
part two will be the next video I
release which I will release on Tuesday
thanks for stopping by for our first
collaboration together make sure you go
subscribe to the rest of the golden
company I will link their channels down
in the description also comment below
and give us your thoughts what do you
predict John snow will be doing next
season let us know thanks we will see
you Tuesday for part two bye